medicare open enrollment ends on
december 7th so hometown health wants to
remind you that they are here to help
here's rocky with more information cj
you're from hometown health dr wadwa
from caremore health this is a new
partnership
this is a brand new partnership we're so
excited to bring the senior care
plus and care more partnership down into
southern nevada
and why is it such a good time for
seniors to focus on their
health care well it's open enrollment
time there's a ton of new plans in the
area
and there's new options for them now
between october 15th and december 7th
and dr wadwa tell us more about this
partnership between your
home your caremore health and hometown
health
yes so this new partnership will allow
us to deliver a really a premier
healthcare solution
and a proven care delivery model to
medicare recipients here in clark county
you know caramel health believes in
taking care of members at caramel we
believe in taking care of members
where they need it be it in their homes
virtually
in any of our three caramel care centers
and when needed in the hospitals
we are really excited about this new
partnership we believe in our model
and together with senior care plus i
believe will help medicare recipients in
las vegas
reach their health care goals and you
mentioned your model tell us more about
that what is the care more model
yeah so for over 25 years caramel has
delivered a
very into a highly integrated
coordinated care
and we do this through various programs
this is preventative medicine
as well as programs to take care of
chronic conditions like chf
diabetes copd we believe in whole person
care at caremore
your karma model will have an
interdisciplinary team of healthcare
professionals which includes doctors
nurse practitioners clinical pharmacists
social workers case management
case managers behavioral health
specialists and other specialists
so we address not only your medical
needs but also any social
barriers to accessing care and your
behavioral health needs
we don't want we want to remove any
barriers to getting care to you
griffin you guys cover it all in cj what
what are the benefits of enrolling in
senior care plus
senior care plus has two plans out there
for individuals versus our
comprehensive plan for any individual
eligible for a medicare advantage plan
it has a wide range of benefits and
including dental options for them
and then we have an encompass plan as dr
wadwood talked about
that is for individuals with copd chf or
diabetes
that gives them that extra level of care
and extra medications that they need
to make sure they're taken care of as
well as dental coverage
and fitness benefits perfect so dr
wadwa cj are there any other final
thoughts you want to share with our
viewers
i think the first one would be just make
sure if you're going to change your plan
or make a plan choice this year
do it before december 7th so you can
start in that new plan on january 1st
dr what about you i think it's an
exciting time
there's a lot of opportunities for
seniors uh here in las vegas so
we are looking forward to helping you uh
and take care of you
well thank you for all of your work and
your services taking care of our seniors
around town i appreciate you guys
thank you for more information call
775-982-3158 or
visit seniorcareplus.com jc over to you